more and more people are getting sick
more addicted more people are dying of
overdoses
my guest today returning for his second
appearance on the show is dr gabor mate
the problem in our society is there's
very little that actually promotes
healing and there's very much that
undermines it he's an expert in a wide
range of topics but is most lauded for
his work on the relationship between
addiction and childhood development this
society loves you to be addicted
feeling inadequate this path of
wholeness is not supported by the
culture in fact is undermined by it dr
mate's latest and most ambitious book to
date the myth of normal investigates the
true causes of illness and the pathway
to health and well-being this addiction
that i have is not a disease that i
inherited but it's my attempt to escape
from pain and the more i learn about
that pain the less i'll inflict those
imprints on myself and on the people
around me so please hit that subscribe
button and here we go round two dr gabor
mate
[Applause]
[Music]
all of our afflictions whether it's
addiction
chronic physical illness
what we call mental illness
dysfunctions
they're all
have a template of childhood wounding
and they they're not
separate
biological events happening in discrete
individuals
but they are representative of a process
inside each of us that manifests a
relationship to our environment
most importantly our early rearing
environment but also the culture that we
live in so that to give you one example
it's an obvious example if you look at
the number of
kids going diagnosed with
say adhd
the numbers are going up all the time
that can't be an individual thing that
has to say something about the culture
the context
if you look at the rising incidence of
autoimmune disease the rising incidence
of addictions of mental health
conditions
if you look at the fact that say black
american women the more experience of
racism they have to endure the greater
the risk for asthma
it just tells us that it's not just
about individual biology it's about
life in a culture
yeah and on that idea of culture you use
this petri dish example to illustrate
that point which i thought was really
powerful because i'd never really
thought of it in that way can you
explain that sure so
when we
are studying microorganisms in a
laboratory
we grow them in a broth we give them a
breath to nourish them you call that a
culture
a cultural medium
and if the organisms in this culture
medium this cultural broth were
dying off in great numbers or not
thriving or or or ill
we would call that a toxic culture
i'm saying that when
in a society like ours more and more
people are getting sick more addicted
more mentally ill more people are
cutting themselves
more people are dying of overdoses
that's also
representative of a toxic culture and
i'm saying that that's what we live in
hence the subtitle of the book
trauma illness and healing in a toxic
culture this culture
is not a not one that supports healthy
human growth
and when you say toxic culture we should
probably define that because it's a
little bit different than what people
might suspect they're thinking of
environmental pollutants and the like
and that's certainly a contributor to a
lot of this but you're really talking
about uh what's going on societally and
and culturally
yes so
that is all true that it has to do with
the physical stuff there was an article
reported just the other day that
half of americans
were exposed to unhealthy levels of lead
when they were kids
you know that's
toxic right but
you're right that's not the toxic that
i'm talking about i'm talking about the
nature of the culture itself the very
values of the culture
the way we bring up children
the expectations we put on human beings
they're toxic to people's healthy
development
it seems so
obvious
and in reading the book it's like of
course this is an issue and yet it's so
highly
unaddressed or or ignored and in reading
the book i couldn't help but uh draw an
analogy to
what you've all know harare is doing in
terms of how we think about history like
telescoping out and looking at
everything from 10 000 feet
which is not something we do when we
think about and talk about health we
narrow down to the cellular level to the
microbe level
and the scientific method dictates that
we control for variables and look at
things in isolation and of course we've
made tremendous progress as a society uh
by by dint of you know the technological
advances that we can make
by utilizing the scientific method but
it's it's a method that's myopic to the
deep interconnectedness of everything it
doesn't allow us to look at things as
holistic systems and the interplay
that is leading to so many of these
problems like we can't address these
diseases in these conditions on their
own without looking at what's
contributing to them
by virtue of external forces well you
know
yes i agree with your formulation but i
would also argue
that
there's all kinds of science
that shows the interconnections of
things
so that to talk about human beings in a
context and that health represents life
in a context rather than just a
biological event
that's science
and we have literally tens of thousands
of
scientific studies to indicate
how
emotional environments affect people's
biology our immune system and our
hormonal apparatus and our nervous
systems and our guts and our hearts and
so on and how social conditions or
inequality how stress
how um
genderism or racism actually has
physiological impacts they're underneath
the skin they affect their biology
this is not speculation
my knock on the medical profession is we
keep talking about evidence-based
practice but we don't look at a lot of
the evidence that started being
published including in major medical
journals so i'm not talking about
insight and
ideology or or spirituality on the one
hand and science on the other i'm
talking about science that is actually
showing the interconnections but there's
such a wide gap between that
understanding and the practice of
medicine or how we treat people
oh yeah clinical there's a huge
what we can call the
science and practice gap right so the
problem is not with the science the
problem is that we don't put the science
into practice the average medical
student does not get it for example i
talk about trauma in this book
and trauma has many implications trauma
has been implicated in
autoimmune disease and cancer and
addictions in every mental health
conditions in in the book
but the average medical student does not
receive a single lecture on trauma which
is unbelievable
but it's true
for the most part there might be a few
exceptions here and there but generally
not secondly doctors are very
traumatized people themselves
medical training is highly traumatic
i've talked to many physicians who
talked about the assault on their
sensibilities by medical school
biologically
medical students age faster than other
people their age because of the stress
they're under
so you got this traumatized population
treating
the larger traumatized population
without any awareness of trauma
so there's a huge gap right let's let's
let's define trauma you have this idea
of the the capital t trauma and the
lowercase t
trauma um and perhaps your definition
differs from what people might
conventionally think about when they
think about trauma
it's true the average person when they
think about trauma they think of
horrible events like a war
um like
extreme abuse physical sexual emotional
abuse
catastrophes
people dying and so on and you know
those are traumatic
but
trauma is not the events
trauma comes from the greek word for
wounding so trauma is a wound that you
sustain
and you can be wounded without
catastrophic events
so those
those traumas the the big
noticeable
terrible events that happen to you
they're called we can call big t trauma
but you can also wound people
not only by hurting them badly but
simply by not meeting their needs
and in this society a lot of children
grow up with their essential human needs
being met
so that's what i call small t trauma
where people aren't doing bad things to
you necessarily
but the good things that should be
happening are not happening so you can
hurt people by bit
hitting them you can also hurt people by
not giving them water so not needing
their needs
in that sense we have certain emotional
needs as human beings as evolved human
beings
that this society not only fails to meet
but actually
tramples on very deliberately and very
chronically so a lot of children get
traumatized not just by what happens to
them but why doesn't but by what doesn't
happen to them that should have happened
right and in that early developmental
stage we develop our attachment
strategies
and we create these sort of uh patterns
that recur over the course of our
lifetime i mean you tell the story in
the book about
um
you know landing at the airport after
coming back from a speaking engagement
and acting like a petulant child because
your wife blew you off to pick you up at
the airport like you're
despite everything that you know there's
some level of powerlessness that we have
in terms of trying to course correct
what has been so cemented well trauma
has a wound that if it doesn't heal it
just keeps acting up so that airport
example is is me arriving back from a
speaking trip at age
72 or 73
and my wife is not there to pick me up
and i go into a rage and i emotionally i
become very withdrawn
which is uh
[Music]
a mirroring of exactly what happened to
me when i was a year old my mother gave
me to a stranger to save my life and i
didn't see her so my mother wasn't
available to me
and when i saw her again after four or
five weeks this is a wartime hungary
i didn't even look at her for several
days which is what an infant does
to protect themselves from the pain of
being abandoned again
so
that wound on us is healed will show up
again even 70 odd years later when the
woman i'm relying on doesn't show up for
me
so that's a traumatic imprint
and um
what happens is that when trauma acts up
the midfrontal cortex the part that's
rational and can respond in the present
moment goes offline
and these traumatic imprints show up and
they govern your behavior so all of a
sudden yes as you say i start acting
like a hurt little child
healing of trauma
is in is in learning to recognize and
cope with these imprints
but
the lack of that healing shows up in
this society in every realm in medicine
in health in mental health uh in the in
in the pop culture
in uh in politics
in economics everywhere right
and in your previous work you've you've
drawn this connective tissue between
trauma and how it shows up uh as how it
can show up as as addiction
later in life with certain individuals
but create that connectivity between
trauma and
for example you know chronic ailments
that we're seeing on the rise across the
world or at least in the developed world
well so there's
there's a rise in autoimmune disease
autoimmune disease are conditions where
the immune system turns against the self
so um and starts destroying the immune
system which is meant to protect us
turns against us and starts destroying
our bodies
now
examples are rheumatoid arthritis
scleroderma lupus chronic fatigue
multiple sclerosis
crohn's disease
ulcerative colitis
chronic psoriasis
autoimmune eczema
one could go on
this is rising in this society
and not only is it rising in a society
as the globalized economic system takes
over more of the world it's rising
internationally
and it's rising particularly amongst
women
now
when i looked at the people who develop
autoimmune disease
it's always related to stress
and
particularly
people's coping styles
so
people with autonomy disease typically
repress their emotions they don't know
how to be contact in contact with their
healthy anger with their healthy anger
they tend to suppress their real selves
to fit in with society and with their
families
and
essentially
when people
don't
experience their healthy anger
[Music]
their anger doesn't go away
it gets suppressed
turns against themselves
now our emotional apparatus is very much
connected to our immune system in fact
they're part and parcel of the same
system
when your emotions turns against us our
immune system can turn against us as
well
in this society because so many people
are not allowed to be themselves they
have to kind of suppress who they are in
order to survive and fit in
we're getting more and more autoimmune
disease
is my view lots of evidence for that
talk a little bit about this this idea
of disease as teacher
yeah
so
i've worked in all areas of medicine
from delivering babies to palliative
care looking after term and ill people
so i've seen a lot of disease as a
physician
what's surprising to me is that
some people
who should resent their illness we all
would naturally nobody wants to get sick
they found that the teacher actually be
sorry that the disease is actually a
teacher to them
because the disease pointed out to them
why they were not living a life that was
authentic
how they were living a life of
self-suppression
an example is a very well-known one
anita murjani who wrote a book called
dying to be me
she was literally on the verge of death
to she and she was terminally ill she
wasn't going to live
and then she had this near-death
experience and she finds out that all
her life she had not been herself
that's why the title dying to be me
at the death's door
she realizes that she needs to be
authentically herself and she actually
recovers
and so that the disease taught her to be
herself i give the example of the great
dramatist and writer v formerly known as
eve ensler who has stage four
uterine cancer she found her disease
taught her essentially to be herself
i'm then i've met people
even in terminal illness who are not
going to recover who did not recover who
said
what i learned was so precious i'm
grateful for my disease i've met people
with addictions
who've said
i wouldn't wish this on anybody but my
god did it teach me yeah that idea you
know the grateful alcoholic yeah
notion it's it's tricky though i mean
this is a sensitive
thing because
to tell somebody or to announce that
your disease is your teacher when
someone is in grave suffering it's it's
sort of like
how dare you you know i don't tell
anybody that i don't tell anybody that i
just give examples of people who have
found it that way
but it's not for me to tell somebody
else with the illness you should be
happy this is a teacher for you i
wouldn't want anybody to tell me that
for god's sakes i'd be very angry if
they did so
it's not that we should tell people they
should fight they should feel
but it's the point that the possibility
is inherent
it in terms of what an illness can offer
people if people choose to go that way
that's their call
if they don't choose to go that way i
totally understand it
yeah baked into this is this idea that
that you know we we sort of think these
things happen
by chance randomly in happenstance
but when you like i said earlier
telescope out and you really
closely analyze the environment
the stress the anxiety
the gestalt of what our kind of modern
existent existence looks like on a
day-to-day basis there's all these
contributing lifestyle factors the food
that we're eating the lack of sleep the
you know the the
whatever light is coming out of this
device that i'm staring into all of
these things are contributing to to
moving us out of balance with the
natural rhythms of how we've
evolved to live in the world and so all
that is all that is true
and then there's the larger issues of um
when you look at the
scientific literature on stress
and by stress i mean
emotional factors that affect your
physiology
your immune system and your hormones and
and everything
what are they the major
factors for stress
are uncertainty
loss of control lack of information
and conflict
now in this society how many people are
living with
loss of control
uncertainty lack of information
insecurity and conflict this system is
almost designed to make people feel
insecure
and
for example the time of economic crisis
they looked at
young people in greece
as compared with sweden which wasn't
having an economic crisis
the stress hormone levels of the young
greeks
were really affected by what's going on
economically
and that promotes inflammation
and the researchers found that actually
said that this is going to affect the
future health of these young greeks
this is a social issue it was an
individual
biological
problem restricted to a single human
being it was a social issue inflicted by
social political and economic conditions
and that happens on a massive scale
under globalized capitalism to a lot of
people right and on top of that there's
this idea of of the loss of connection
interconnectivity between human beings
you and i both know johan hari and he
has written books about this and speaks
about this but
we're in this era in which we feel
hyper-connected by by virtue of our
devices and yet
most of us are suffering from some level
of loneliness uh that that you know is
endemic to this period of time
well i could speak a whole hour about
the impact of the devices about how the
device themselves are designed to keep
people addicted including very young
kids that's a separate issue the issue
of loneliness
so if you look at the number of people
who described themselves as being lonely
in the united states that's doubled
within 20 years
and
loneliness is a major factor for
physical illness as smoking 15
cigarettes a day or as high blood
pressure or obesity
and
loneliness has been spreading in the
western world again under the impact of
a globalized economic system that pits
people against one another that says
that competition and aggression and
mistrust of others is the way to survive
and which has
in many many ways documented ways
um devoted communities and extended
families and has cut down on people's
sense of community
[Music]
loneliness is going up and that's posing
a major risk factor people who are
lonely get sicker faster and they die
sooner of their diseases
so that's a major problem in western
societies
what catalyzed your interest in in
writing this book
i mean obviously it does feel to me to
to be a natural progression of the work
that you've already done uh but why you
know sort of shift your focus away from
what was kind of keenly honed on
addiction and and broaden it
well you know it was a natural uh
progression um
for example i'm a canadian i live in
canada
so when i worked with a with a highly
addicted population in vancouver's
downtown eastside but you visited the
first time that
we met
30 this is north america's most
concentrated area of drug use we have
more people using injecting inhaling
substances than anywhere else in north
america
and
30 of my clients down there were
indigenous canadians non-agents
canadians make up five percent of the
canadian population thirty percent of
the addicted population thirty percent
of the jail population indigenous women
make up fifty percent of the canadian
jail population amongst women
now
clearly there's a link between
um
social economic and racial status and
illness so that you can't help but
notice that right so
then you have to start asking what are
the factors on a social level that
promote addiction that promote mental
illness that promotes suicide that
promote physical illness now if
first nations canadian an indigenous
canadian woman has this time six times
the rate of rheumatoid arthritis
been that much higher than anybody else
six times
uh women of color in the u.s has much
higher rates of autoimmune disease than
non-people who are considered
not people of color now these are these
problems are not genetic
the indigenous published in canada had
no autoimmune disease before
colonization at all
it's social economic racial and
historical so that you can't help but
notice these things and by the way
i'm far from the first one in the 19th
century there was a german physician
renowned in the history of medicine
rudolf virtua his name was and
he he said that politics is just the
extension of medicine that if we're
going to deal with people's health we
have to deal with the politics so this
awareness is not new
but it's like that science and the
mind-body unity that i was referring to
where we have the science but the
profession doesn't
take it into account right and it's the
same with this
link between the individual and society
again the medical profession does not
take it into account despite the
abundant evidence there does seem to be
a growing awareness around
generational trauma and you know the
kind of tangential implications of that
as well as the epigenetic which is sort
of related right the epigenetic nature
of this which is to say that
that um
we have the
genetic code and the epigenetics are
what kind of toggle on and off
these adaptive strategies and behaviors
so epi means on top of separate genetics
means on top of genetics really and
what you're referring to is the
fact that genes
are turned on and off by the environment
they're not independent actors
so you can have people with the same
genes
but different environments they'll have
very different outcomes
and so that's epigenetics and to some
extent those epigenetics can be passed
on to future generations
we know that from animal studies
so that
when you look at one generation you
can't understand it without looking at
the previous generation as well so that
the connection the connection i'm
talking about is both
lateral in the sense that it spreads
throughout the whole culture but it's
also vertical in that it spreads across
the generations right so if you were to
take
uh a native american population in north
america and and just track the incidence
of alcoholism which is known to be
higher in those communities there's a
generational trauma piece to that and an
epigenetic piece to that well the
generational trauma is genocide and
oppression and loss of lands and
livelihood and the deprivation of
culture
the deliberate destruction of spiritual
ways all this happened in canada and in
the u.s
in canada
native children were abducted from their
homes for 100 years and forced to go
into these residential schools
where they couldn't see their parents
but they were forbidden to see their
parents
and where they were sexually physically
abused where their culture was
denigrated
where
they just found thousands of bodies of
these children in canada who died in
israeli schools now
those that survived the venture schools
and went home
their whole childhood had been robbed
from them
their parenting was taken away their
nurturing connections were destroyed
they didn't know how to parent the next
generation and this went on for 100
years
so in the native communities in canada
we have much more alcoholism much more
child abuse
this is contrary how they used to raise
children these indigenous people raise
children in much more healthier ways
than we do right
right i mean we need to learn for how
they raise children
and i could talk about that but
because how dare his children was how we
evolved as human beings
were meant to raise children
by evolution
so we destroyed that for them
and now we wonder why do they have more
alcoholism why do they have more
addiction why do they have more illness
why do they have more violence it's
because we've
robbed them of their nature
and so when i talk about a
toxic society i'm talking about a
society in which what is normal is
completely unnatural and unhealthy
yeah
but this of course is
is is rampant across
all sectors of the developed world i
wrote down some of the statistics that
you you cite in the book i mean 60
of
us adults have a chronic disorder 40
have more
than more than one such disorder 70 of
us adults are on at least one
prescription drug 50 take two 20 of
canadians have high blood pressure 30
percent of europeans have hypertension i
mean it just goes on and on and on right
yeah so nobody's immune from this no
no something is terribly awry like we
are completely out of balance
we're out of balance um
here's the thing
we're out of balance
now
that
that imbalance affects some people more
than others but it does affect everybody
there's no strata there's no stratum of
society that expec that escapes the
stresses
and um
where we're out of balance is that
we have certain needs as human beings
see children have four basic needs
they have a need to
be strongly attached to adults to take
care of them
when we're with them all the time by the
way because as we evolved as human
beings over millions of years and for
most of our species
existence as homo sapiens we lived in
small communities where the parents were
always around the kids so secure
attachments mm-hmm
and extended family extended family
community right you know and
then children have a need not to have to
work to make their relationship with the
parents work they have to be able to
rest in a security that there's nothing
they can do to destroy the relationship
and there's nothing they need to do to
make it work they're in our society we
make our kids work
to be accepted you have to be good you
have to be smart you have to be
good looking or you have to be you have
to be behave acceptably otherwise you're
going to get a time out and we're going
to say to you no you can't be with us
we're going to deprive you over contact
for a little while
[Music]
jordan peterson
canadian psychologist says that an angry
child shouldn't made to sit by
themselves until they come back to
normal in other words it's not normal
for a kid to be angry well let me tell
you it's very normal for a two-year-old
to be angry because they get frustrated
now if you give the message to a
two-year-old you're not acceptable to me
when you're angry basically you're
saying to them don't be yourself
suppress who you are in order to be
accepted your love is conditional yes
love is conditional that's the message
you're given yeah a lot of kids in this
society are getting the message that
love is conditional we tell parents
not to pick up their sleep not to pick
up their crying babies
are you telling them
they need to learn how to be okay being
without that nurturing that's so crucial
on that no you tell a mother gorilla not
to pick up their baby when it's crying
or tell a mother cat to ignore the
little kids
meowing you know
but
so so that
children have the need to be able to
experience all their emotions fully
and that be accepted by the parents
well we tell parents no your children's
anger is not acceptable
so it shouldn't get the message that
then are acceptable you have to work to
be acceptable you have to suppress
yourself to be acceptable
and children need free play out there in
nature free play not with gadgets not
with cell phones not with games on the
internet but free play in nature this is
our essential needs of human beings
that goes into the the four that are
really six this like six a's that you
talk about in the book right and then
the agency would be like the ability to
like roam and be outdoors and attachment
being important as well well
attachment is well
authenticity agency
anger anger
um
acceptance autonomy
you know
um
these are
these are the healing pathways what i'm
saying is for people to heal
they have to find their own agency they
have to
whatever happens to them they need to
participate in the decisions that affect
their lives particularly the health
decisions
so for that and so the uh
it's very interesting there's a couple
of people that i know
who have looked at what's called
spontaneous remission
spontaneous remission is supposedly when
somebody spontaneously gets better after
having been given a terminal diagnosis
and there's a
psychiatrist at harvard dr jeff rediger
who by the way you might want to talk to
some time
he's written a book called cured the the
the
the science of spontaneous healing he
studied people just as i have
who got better
despite giving terminal diagnosis
after the failure of medical treatment
or even if they if they refused medical
treatment
kelly turner dr kelly turner is an
oncological psychologist who worked with
cancer patients
and she also did a study of people who
are spontaneously better
spontaneously
but when i talk to these people when
kelly turner or jeff rediger talks to
these people there's nothing spontaneous
about the healing they all did something
and the biggest thing they did is they
developed a different relationship to
themselves they became authentically
themselves
they stopped pleasing people they
actually consulted what they needed and
wanted within themselves
now i'm not saying that this is a magic
cure all but i'm saying that the people
that do get better
on their own with or without medical
treatment in the face of terminal
diagnosis they're the ones who took
agency over their lives
and
in our medical system people are made to
be very passive recipients you're the
experts do tell me what
so agency is very very important healthy
anger is very important
uh healthy anger is um
well i i begin chapter two i think with
the case of a woman who's given a
diagnosis of um
two years to live with
metastatic breast cancer
and
the doctor is telling her that the
statistics means that she's got two
years to live now she's got two young
kids
and she says to the doctor [ __ ] your
statistics
she says that was very rude i said what
do you mean she says i said to him [ __ ]
your statistics
i said to her thanks that's great that
probably helped you survive she lived
another 20 years because she got partly
because she stopped being a people
pleaser and she got in touch with a
healthy anger she did die over cancer
but only after she raised her kids to be
young successfully yeah she said like i
have to i need to raise these boys like
i can't die yet i have work to do
exactly and
and one of them ended and she did she 20
years and one goes on to princeton or
something like that so she fulfilled
that and in the book i give examples
never mind terminal illness people with
multiple sclerosis who've been told they
have to be on medications for theirs to
their lives
they're okay with that medication now
and they have no symptoms people with
rheumatoid arthritis the same thing why
because they
got in touch with their real cells they
stopped
suppressing themselves they stopped
trying to please everybody else they
said who am i what do i need what am i
interested
what do i need to say no to what i need
to say yes to
and
i'm telling you a lot of these
conditions
who are which are considered to be
chronic
and incurable
they're not
necessarily you know and uh
the case i give in the book of a woman
with sclerodermas scleroderma is uh
autoimmune disease sclerosis means
hardening derma skin scleroderma is
hardened skin
in scleroderma the connective tissues of
your body gets stiff and this woman at
age 29
she said i was being mummified alive she
became like a rigid mummy she could
barely move she could not get out of bed
her by herself the medications failed
they didn't work for her all she wanted
to do was die
now she's walking around hiking
writing her autobiography winning poetry
contests
because she turned her relationship
because she dealt with her childhood
trauma
which none of the doctors asked her
about of course
and she become authentically herself
and and
these are not fairy tales i talked to
the dog i talked to a physician
who verified the story mm-hmm yeah me
oak
this is
she happened to do it through
her healing happened through
um an experience with a psychedelic
uh which allowed her to recognize her
true self
and a lot of other work besides
but
what's the message here the message here
is that
illness
is a manifestation of a person's trauma
and a person's life
and if you turn that life around you can
very often have a positive impact on the
illness as well
right
so the first step is recognizing that
although we think of trauma in a certain
way that on some level we all have
experienced a version of trauma that has
cemented certain behavior patterns
adaptive strategies defense mechanisms
that dictate how we perceive the world
and behave in the world
and many of us if not the majority of us
live our live out you know the rest of
our lives without really ever addressing
that or looking inward to you know
unpack why that is and and try to find a
healthier adaptive strategy right
and short of a life-threatening crisis
that compels us
to do that kind of interior work of
course that choice is available to us
right but it's much more difficult when
you're not in pain you know it's the
same thing in addiction of course so how
how does one like if someone is
listening to this and they're like
wow i never thought i could
take take the reins of control over
these sorts of things
how would i begin to do that
well first of all thank you you
summarized the thesis of my book very
succinctly
um
we don't have to wait for illness to
for us to deal with our stuff day i
quote this greek playwright escalus who
said that the way that god's created us
we human beings we have to suffer
suffer into the truth
and that's often the way it works i mean
i tell you
i went through my own stuff i had my
mental health conditions my adhd my
depression
my relationship problems my stressed
marriage the way that i
transmitted my own trauma into my kids
and
[Music]
unfortunately most of us until things go
sideways we don't
we're not much impel to do anything
about it we just kind of take life as it
goes and i'm okay
well
but we don't have to wait for serious
illness like multiple sclerosis or
rheumatoid arthritis or a serious mental
health crisis or severe addiction to
wake us up
so we can wake up and recognize that
yeah you know
[Music]
stuff happened to me and that's
affecting how i
conduct my relationship i am with my in
my marriage how i'm
with my friends how i show up for my
work whether i'm addicted to work or
with them i'm not whether i pursue some
addiction or not whether it's sex
pornography or gambling or substances or
shopping or eating um these all
represent some kind of traumatic imprint
and i can deal with it i can learn to
deal with it now so it doesn't have to
get more severe yeah so we don't have to
wait for that disease as the teacher to
show up
yeah i think a an honest and thorough
inventory as they say yeah is more than
revealing if you want to kind of do a
little self-analysis on on what makes
you tick and
you know i just know that that
you know it's it's common to witness
people who say
i need to lose weight i'm going to try
this diet or i'm going to you know i'm
going to adopt a meditation practice or
i'm going to start an exercise routine
or i'm going to go on a 30-day digital
detox
and more often than not you can be
successful in those temporary pursuits
but you quickly rubber band and default
to your core setting
and that's discouraging for most people
but i think it's also
illustrative of just how deeply embedded
how ingrained these patterns are that
you reflexively go back to the way you
always did it after this little
experiment and should give you a sense
of how
powerful this pattern patterning is and
what you're up against because it is it
is it's a beast right and as somebody
who's been you know
who embarked upon this in 1998 and has
you know been in recovery for a long
time
it's you're continually peeling these
layers and just when you think you have
a handle on something the degree of
difficulty continues to increase and
this will be the case until i'm in a
coffin like the more i think i have a
handle on it the more baffled and and
amazed i am at how much work remains and
how much i still
you know my wife is a great mirror as
i'm sure yours is like you're behaving
like your mother again like you're
you're literally developing these
everything that you
dislike about how she behaves like i'm
seeing it right now and i was like you
got to be kidding me like i've worked so
hard
to transcend this and yet it continues
to show up well
yeah so a number of things the buddha
talked about our habit energies
and they're deeply ingrained
so it's a question of do you just want
to change behaviors
or do you deal with do you want to deal
with the underlying imprint that drives
those behaviors
so in the first case we can change the
behaviors for a while but if we don't
deal with the underlying imprints those
behaviors are going to reassert
themselves right number one number two
it's not as discouraging as all that i
mean
it's true these patterns can still show
up in my life i'm 78 now they can still
show up but believe me they don't show
up with the same force and the same
dictatorial authority as they showed up
even three or four years ago so there's
such a thing as progress and as far as
the work you're right it's lifelong work
i don't know if i told you but i've
written my epitaph
oh no i don't know what it is oh my
gravestone it's going to be engraved it
was a lot more work than i had
anticipated
[Laughter]
so
but you know what what's the alternative
the alternative is to vegetate and
and rot and to
keep stuck in old painters the problem
in our society is there's very little
that actually promotes healing and
there's very much that undermines it
so that this society loves you to be
addicted
it loves you to be
feeling inadequate so that you're trying
to
meet other people's expectations
it loves you to try to fit in
instead of being authentically yourself
jamie lee jamie lee curtis said to me
once that
in this society there's a genocide of
authenticity
this culture kills authenticity so that
this
this this path towards wholeness
in the last chapter of the book is
called pathways to wholeness
this pathos wholeness is not supported
by the culture in fact it's undermined
by it so we have to kind of take it on
for ourselves not just as necessary as
individuals but in the face of cultural
programming and propaganda
prophets walk among us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years i've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing
and so i've dedicated my career to
tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why i'm proud to announce the release of
my new book
voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration
and timeless wisdom that transpires each
week on the ritual podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying stand-alone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday prophets
and physically interact with the
life-changing ideas contained within
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
in that final chapter about wholeness
there's a extended discussion about
building in
uh into our institutions a better
understanding of trauma like
trauma-based medicine and how we
understand trauma
even in the legal system because yes
culture loves to addict us but then they
also love to tell us that we are
afflicted and broken and we must be you
know put incarcerated and punished as
opposed to a holistic understanding of
the trauma that led to the behavior and
figuring out a way to rehabilitate that
person by you know confronting the
underlying condition that's driving the
behavior yeah so in that last chapter i
do talk about the need for a trauma in
front medical system which you don't
have the need for trauma from legal
system which we don't have the legal
system
if a patient of mine
in the downtown eastside
was caught selling an ounce of cocaine
he'd go to jail
but if you're a corporation that tells
that deliberately sells toxic substances
that kill hundreds of thousands
you're a successful executive
if you're a pharmaceutical company
executive whose products
knowingly
were addictive
and have killed
hundreds of thousands of people
you get rewarded with high profits
and dividends
if you sell an ounce of
heroin
you're in jail for maybe for the rest of
your life in this country you know so
that
now if the legal system understood that
most of the people in jails are actually
traumatized people
that the violence and the drug use and
so on came out of trauma
then we would really create a legal
system that rehabilitates people
that deals with the trauma that helps
them redeem themselves
and helps them overcome their patterns
that could be done we know how to do it
is is is there a country that is
effectively doing that is it norway or
there's so well there's a couple
countries so there are countries that do
it a lot better than north america does
or most of the world actually so um
in portugal as you and i know yeah um
there's no there's no um
uh punishment anymore for possessing
drugs for personal use as a result
there's less use and more people getting
treatment in some of the scandinavian
countries they have jails that are
really designed to rehabilitate people
that treat people humanely it's not a
question of excusing what they did but
it was a question of how to move
forward so that they don't do it again
and that's called rehabilitation so the
jails are much less punitive much more
humane
right and
therefore much more successful
on this idea of trauma-based medicine
ideally this would look like like if
somebody comes into a clinician's office
and says i'm i have like this gut
problem or i have you know some kind of
skin condition or autoimmune disorder
yeah
the
the practitioner would say tell me about
your life like what are you going
through what is your day like what are
you eating how are you sleeping well
what is your childhood yeah well in our
fairness fairness i would not begin with
that i would say tell me about your
problem and this year we can help you in
the short term so that you don't suffer
and when i've stabilized when we've
stabilized your condition
can we talk about the conditions in your
life that may have contributed to the
onset of your illness
now can we talk about your childhood can
we talk about your relationship can we
talk about your stress levels can we
talk about how you feel about yourself
can we talk about
what your marriage is like
we know for example the stressful
marriages
affect people's immune systems
so these questions are very pertinent i
wouldn't that would be the first thing
that i would if you're come into me with
an inflamed skin right if it's if it
right if it's in a heightened situation
yeah
if you come to me with any skin
inflammation you wouldn't thank me if i
started asking about your childhood
but deal with the acute nature but if i
said let's deal with the acute problem
and then let's talk about some of the
conditions that may have stressed you so
that you your skin got inflamed or that
your guts got inflamed or your joints
got inflamed now that would be a healthy
conversation most physicians don't even
know how to ask those questions
are you
uh sanguine about this changing
i don't have a short term optimism i
think it's going to take a long time
it's going to take a lot of work
you know yesterday i was speaking at a
conference
in san diego on psychedelics and healing
and there was a physician there
an internal medicine specialist from
california
and she said i so agree with you our
profession is so backward it's so i you
know
we're so traumatized as physicians our
knowledge is so limited and we so
separate things that are actually
connected in real life
um
how do we move forward well there's more
and more physicians asking those
questions
there's more physicians being aware the
institutions of medicine have a long way
to go
yeah and
that's going to take a long time when we
talk about trauma
one thing that that concerns me and i'm
interested in in your take on this
is
is the idea that it can be fueling this
sense of
victimhood that leads to
helplessness because right now we're
kind of
um celebrating victimhood like it's
almost as if there's a contest who's the
biggest victim and people are crafting
identities around that
and i think the healthy aspect of that
is that people are talking about their
trauma and confronting it so it's become
part of the parlance of our mainstream
conversation
but the unhealthy part of that is the
self-identification with the victim
aspect of it that breeds helplessness
but is also something that gets
validated like in social media for
example so how do you parse that well as
you say it's a fine line because a lot
of people are traumatized in this
society and um
the more we recognize that the better
and i'm very glad when a celebrity comes
out and says i was traumatized or
sexually abused i was hurt and that
really affected my life
and it fueled my addiction or fooled my
fueled my illness or it fueled my
uh
depression
that's important
but also as you say
and in the book we talk about this is
that
that doesn't mean we should identify as
victim
so recognizing what happened
doesn't necessarily create a victim
identity
the victim identity says this happened
to me
and i'm
helpless in the face of it well that
goes against my concept of agency
so in order to be able to exercise
agency you got to let go of the
victimhood yes i was a traumatized
jewish infant under the nazis that's my
reality there's nothing i can do that
that's what happened but i don't have to
live the rest of my life
by what i
made that mean at the time
and so that's the whole thing of healing
is that you recognize what happened you
you fearlessly
look at it you don't deny it anymore but
at the same time
you work not to let that define who you
are how you move forward
how you see the world
yeah
because
trauma again is not what happened to you
it's what happened inside you as a
result of what happened to you and
that's the good news because if trauma
was what happened to you
that somebody sexually abused you
or that your parents died in a war
if that was the trauma there's nothing
you can do to change that that happened
it was never not going to have happened
but if the trauma is the wound that you
incurred in inwardly you can heal that
wound at any time
right so actually the
recognizing what trauma is is an
internal psychological wound
with manifestations in your body
actually allows you to heal it first you
have to recognize that that there is a
wound i mean one of the things that you
did with me that was so powerful when we
first sat down
was to kind of walk me through my
history because
i like i think a lot of people
am very you know resistant to
you know point a finger at either of my
parents and you talk a lot about this
distinction between
responsibility and blame like i and and
so i think
you know my reluctance
to
you know think about culpability in my
child rearing has held held me in a
place where i wasn't able to
really honestly inventory
what occurred and link it to how i you
know began to behave as i as i as i grew
older so
unpacking that and and creating a
you know sort of a safe environment to
speak about that i think is really
instructive in helping people
you know understand the relationship
between their development and
where they're where they are now in life
and and how those things are
inextricably connected yes so in this
book we
take a fair bit of trouble to point out
that blaming anybody is
is inappropriate unscientific and cruel
actually and not helpful
um
at the same time
we show people that the assumptions they
made about their lives were
very often based on suppressing their
real emotions
so uh i've had so many conversations
with people that i had a perfectly happy
childhood and
then i issue what i call the happy
childhood challenge which takes uh
it takes me about three minutes yeah
you're very you could get right to it
pretty quickly yeah well it's not that
difficult
um
because for example
if i was talking to you knowing you've
had four children
uh
if i just asked
what would be like for one of your
children to experience what you
experienced
what would you say right away yeah i
mean it's it would be
it would be a
very painful yeah and and i think sorry
to interrupt but just to interject one
one point on that
i think that i find myself parenting in
opposition to the way i was raised
and perhaps to a fault right this
pendulum swings too far in the other
direction
and even despite that
under moments of duress or stress
i will repeat a pattern that mimics
exactly what my parents did yeah yeah
yeah those are those imprints that
you haven't quite worked through yet
right um
believe me if i could do my parenting
over again
we i we wouldn't we all we all would you
know but
that's the whole point
on the other hand i can tell you that
i used to be so worried about my
children about because of
the environment that they grew up in as
a result of my wives and i unresolved
traumas
but you know what
they're doing great
and and uh
they've dealt with it so we also mustn't
humans are also very resilient yeah yeah
and you know and we mustn't project
their anxieties and our guilt onto our
kids either you know that doesn't help
them anyway at all so that's one thing
in in moments of weakness i've been
known to do that yeah
yes and and it's again it's my wife
who's like you're doing that thing
yeah well thank god for our partners
mm-hmm
i think i think i say some remember the
book that uh
i made my own lie detector right right
yeah do i say that in the book yeah i
think it was it was after you know you
were grumpy and is you know storming
around the house for a couple days after
your wife didn't pick you up and finally
she told her one day all right
she told you to just get over it and
snap out of it yeah yeah which um
years ago would have taken me much many
years ago it would take me much longer
to snap out of it the fact that i could
snap out of it after one day that's a
sign of progress you know what
now she wouldn't put up with it for five
minutes
because she knows i can do better yeah
and uh you know we'd be remiss in not
mentioning that you you're you wrote
this book with your son yeah what an
incredible
beautiful experience to have or maybe it
was terrible i don't know what was that
what was the collaboration like
well it had its terrible moments
my son daniel and i i might he's my
eldest child um
we had a kind of fraught relationship
um but you know what this book has been
a beautiful process
and
mostly the problem came from my anxiety
look i was really anxious writing this
book at times because i thought
this time i've bitten off more than i
can show you yeah you're really going
out there yeah this time i'm going to
expose my incompetence and ignorance to
the for the whole world to see
and so in that in in that state of
anxiety because this book was so
important to me
because it's everything i always wanted
to say
so
because of that anxiety
i'd lay sort of
my anxiety onto my son which is the last
thing he needs is to get his father's
anxiety he lived without all his
childhood
so you can see we got triggered at times
but we worked it out beautifully and at
the end it was such a friendly and
fruitful
um productive collaboration and i'm just
so grateful that it went that way yeah
well it's a it's a remarkable
achievement i really do think that this
is a
you know a quantum leap in your in your
thinking and in your writing and i have
no doubt it's going to impact a lot of
people
um
because it really is it speaks directly
to the heart of what ails us in the
broadest sense you know and casts
you know a a road map for a better
future i mean we're all we're not
unaware of all of these problems we all
know what's going on and to better
understand it and figure out how to
redress it for
ourselves and future generations is is i
can think of no you know greater
expenditure of your time and energy well
thank you so much for saying so um
if i may come back to an analogy that we
introduced in a very introduction to the
book
the late
great writer david foster wallace told
this anecdote about
at a commencement address she gave it a
university
and of course he succumbed didn't he
yeah committed suicide in the end
but he um
he gave this analogy of two young fish
swimming along and they meet an older
fish and the older fish says to them hey
boys how's the water
and the two fish swim along for a while
and one of them says to you there what
the heck is water and
point being as
as foster wallace points out
that when something is so close to us
we don't even recognize it
and and and
not recognizing and not dealing with
what's going on is can have fatal
consequences this is what he said
and so in our society this is the water
that we swim in so we take it to be
normal and we don't recognize how
unhealthy unnaturally it actually is
and that has fatal consequences yeah for
millions of people and and and
for people's
well-being and their emotional balance
so
i i just think it's essential to
recognize
not just as we said right in the
beginning not just individual problems
but to recognize that these individual
problems are manifestations of a vast
cultural edifice
that we're all a part of and need to
address
later in the book you you call it the
willingness to be disillusioned
yeah
yeah people when people talk about
well i give three examples i i
i grew up in communist hungary and i was
a good little
believer
snapping to attention when they
mentioned party and leader and plotting
you know and in unison with my
classmates
and then came the hungarian revolution
of 1956.
which um
was brutally put down by the russians by
the soviet army the same sovereign army
that saved my life as an infant
so i got disillusioned i lost my
illusions
then i came to the west canada and
[Music]
believing in the capitalist system and
what they call democracy which i don't
think is that much of a democracy by the
way um
um it's more like a corporatocracy uh
but believing that this is the answer
then the vietnam war happens
and i see the televised slaughter of
millions of vietnamese peasants
so i get disillusioned with that
and then
as the jew and
whose family suffered so much in the
holocaust
i get all excited by the idea of the
jewish state
and
but this is the answer and then i
realized
yeah
[Music]
we established a jewish state but at
whose expense
at the expense of the local population
who on whom was imposed great killing
and great suffering and great
dispossession which is still going on
i get this illusion one more time
when people use the word disillusionment
they always talk about it as a sense of
loss or or betrayal or disappointment
but what i say to people is
would you rather be illusioned or
disillusioned
would you rather believe what is not
true or would you rather see reality so
i think it's essential that we be
disillusioned
that we lose our illusions about the
nature of the world that we live in
because if we don't do that we can't
address the problems
yeah so in the context of this book it's
shattering the illusion that the
conveniences of modern life are making
our lives better and more fulfilled when
in truth they are
putting distance between ourselves and
our true nature and making us
progressively
more sick
losing
exactly
electric illusions i mean we keep being
told that this is the richest and the
best society ever
look what happened in the covet
the richest most powerful society in the
world the united states had by far the
highest incidence of covet
of anywhere in the world
now what does that tell us
that maybe there's a gap between what we
believe about ourselves and the reality
that this most functional and best of
all societies makes most more people
sick than anywhere else in the world i
mean
that ought to give us some pause
shouldn't it
switching gears a little bit because i
can't you know i i can't have you
sitting across from me without
talking about addiction a little bit i'm
interested
in in how your
your perspective has evolved or hasn't
evolved since the last time we talked uh
you know has any of your
thoughts on this changed matured evolved
on the nature of addiction how to treat
it
what have you learned in the intervening
years between you know in the realm of
hungry ghosts and the myth of normal
well
it's virtually impossible to say this
without being arrogant but um i'll take
that risk
um
everything i wrote in the neural fungal
goes has only been proven more and more
by the science and by experience
um what's become even more apparent when
i wrote that book there wasn't this
overdose crisis yet
at least not in the
general population there was for example
in the indigenous population in canada
or the us but of course it only happens
indigenous people who cares about it you
know mm-hmm right until they get noticed
yeah i mean we don't notice it
well there's just those people
now it's happening in the general
society
[Music]
which only means that there's even more
of a need to look at the general
conditions in a society that foster
addictions
um
i would say
the one thing that's changed for me uh
is that
when people say
in general about disease but also by
addiction
i have a disease i have multiple
sclerosis or i have rheumatoid arthritis
or i have adhd or i have depression or i
have addiction i don't talk about it
that way anymore
because there's an implicit assumption
in that way of languaging things
as i sit here
i have this cup here i have a cop i can
put it down i can shatter it i can throw
it away i can give it away i can put it
in my pocket it's a thing it's not me
to say that i have an addiction
or even to say that i am an addict
is that assumes that there's this thing
called an addiction then there's me and
i have this thing
this thing is not
about me somehow just something that i
have
distinct for me or i have adhd this is
this thing called adhd with the life of
its own with characteristics of its own
with the trajectory of its own and then
there's me over here and i have this
thing
but actually
the adhd is a manifestation of my life
it's a process that's happening inside
me
the multiple sclerosis is not a separate
thing with a life of its own it's a
process that's happening inside me the
addiction is not a separate thing that i
have it's a process that's happening
inside me which means that if i change
the process
i have a way of affecting
this thing that we call disease or
addiction
or anything else so
it's more less of a separation between
myself
and what's happening inside me
and even the language
um
i am an addict
it identifies the person with a
particular habit with a particular
dysfunction well
there's
some honesty to that and there's a value
to it because
it means i'm no longer in denial so
that's a good thing
so when somebody at a 12-step meeting
steps up and says i'm so-and-so and i'm
a hawk
i'm an alcoholic well that's honest and
that's taking ownership and that's good
but there's also risk in it is that
people identify
with a particular set of behaviors in a
particular set of imprints and patterns
nobody is their dysfunction that's not
who anybody is
nobody is a victim nobody is an addict
that's not who anybody is
right so to follow that logic
in the context of of 12-step identifying
as an alcoholic hi my name is rich i'm
an alcoholic
uh there is
a baked in notion in that paradigm that
once an alcoholic always an alcoholic
that you are in recovery but you will
never be recovered and i think that
drives
uh that level of of self-identification
with the disease using the disease
paradigm yeah but your
your your your your logic would depart
from that or your thesis departs from
that in the sense that that if the if
the underlying trauma is resolved if you
heal that inner child and whatever is
driving that those behaviors that you
can indeed
be recovered
well and along the way
avoiding
self-identification with this
um
can be a tool to aid in that healing
process so that's your your kind of
departure line from a traditional
12-step it's more radical than that
actually yeah um
yes it's true what you say but it's also
more radical than that
um
first of all let's look at this word
recovery um what does it mean
it means to
find something when you recover
something you find it if i talk to
anybody who's recovered from addiction
or even illness very often i asked them
what did you recover what did you find
they said i found myself
which is the whole theme of the book
is that the loss of self in this culture
is the source of pathology
um so that that self is always always
available to be recovered that's the
whole point
i just want to finish okay because
even somebody who's heavily drinking
right now
if they say i'm an alcoholic i say no
you're not that's not who you are
you're a person who's in so much pain
right now that you're using the alcohol
to numb your pain but you're not
that's not all who you are
so that
it's not just a recovered person who's
no longer an alcoholic even the
alcoholic is not an alcoholic in the
sense that i'm talking about right now
yes they're drinking yes they're hurting
themselves yes they're destroying their
lives that's all true
can't be denied needs to be acknowledged
but what if we said
what if we outlawed the word addict
and you couldn't say about anybody
that so-and-so is an addict what if he
had to say about them so-and-so
is a human being who suffered a lot in
life
and then right now they're trying to
escape from their suffering to this
particular behavior
that acknowledges the truth without
identifying the person with the behavior
yeah i get that i get that i think the
way that i've that i've thought about it
in that
rubric of like
in recovery versus recovered yeah is
similar to the idea like to to
extrapolate or analogize to the idea of
pursuing enlightenment like
i am in pursuit of something
i will not i will unlikely become an
enlightened being in this lifetime but i
will i'm committed to
you know pursuing
higher planes of awareness consciousness
self-understanding self-integration
self-actualization all of those things
so
so
similarly
you know recovery is something that
happens along a spectrum you're always
like pursuing greater and greater
recovery which is self-actualization on
some level but i don't know that i will
ever be recovered because that denotes a
destination that's really kind of an
illusion because there's always more
growth and healing that can be
experienced well i agree with that and
and and partly it's a question of how we
use language you know and what do we
make words mean
interesting you should mention
self-actualization because that comes up
on the very last page of the book
and the um
it was the psychologist uh i think
abraham maslow right who studied
self-actualization
and what he found in a famous study
self-actualized people are authentically
themselves and find the satisfaction in
that
and and what he found is that
the people that are self-actualized
actually are not normal by society's
standards in fact they tend to
either implicitly explicitly
resist society's values and expectations
so that
that what does that tell us about a
culture that the people who are
self-actualized have to actually
express them independence from the
culture that they live in right and a
culture that is driving them towards you
know adherence to a certain set of norms
i mean you talk about in this book you
talk about that in this book how people
who are on that path are often at odds
with their peers or their friends or
whatever what have you um it's
interesting that you bring that up
because i just had
uh this psychologist in here scott barry
kaufman have you ever met him he wrote
this wonderful book called
transcend okay and he's obsessed with
maslow and he just did a deep dive into
maslow's life
and
and extrapolates on his work which was
not complete when he died in 1970.
that's right and gets into you know the
the higher
aspects of that hierarchy when it comes
to um self-actualization and ultimately
transcendence which is
which is you know drawing unison between
the self-actualization process and then
in turn finding a way to channel it in
service to others for the betterment of
humanity which is like the pinnacle
right and is that not
similar to this idea of recovery being
on that same kind of
trajectory
you can formulate it that way sure yeah
yeah it's interesting though because
and we talked about this last time like
i'm i'm a product of
of 12 step and aaa and that comes with a
certain
set of you know
uh
ideas and ideologies there's an ad
indoctrination you know to that process
and because i've been in it so long
i find myself resistant or like my back
gets up when that paradigm gets
challenged because it did save my life
and i've seen it save the lives of so
many other people yeah and that's not to
say that it's that it should be thought
of in calcified terms and we can't
iterate on it or or improve it but i
still have yet to see
anything that would convince me that
there's a better way
and that we should abandon this thing
that is highly imperfect but also
miraculous
well so
first of all
both in my book on addiction and normal
goals and in this book i acknowledge the
value of the twelve steps that's awesome
movement
without
get you without trying to get you too
wrangled here i it's okay you can rank
on me this is what we're here about i'm
happy to rank on anybody
professional wrangler um
i see limitations that i think that if
they moved past it they could even do
better work
because the
i don't know what the statistics are but
the best statistics i've seen about the
12 steps is they help about 20 of the
people
now
i think that's great and it's as good as
it gets but i think it would get better
what if they actually
for example formally
incorporated trauma awareness
now i know that the trauma awareness can
come up for some people in the 12-step
program but it's rather haphazard and uh
you know bill w himself was a
traumatized child abandoned by his
parents why don't we talk about that
more it would really help people
tremendously i've had a lot of people
tell me who have been through 12 steps
who read my book or heard my podcast on
addiction and they say thank you it
finally makes sense to me so it would
take nothing away from the 12 steps
to be more
trauma informed
yeah it would also take it would also
take nothing away from the 12 steps to
use the language from i'm ray tramino
i'll call like i'm grabber and i'm an
addict so on but at the same time
recognizing
that no and that's not that's that's not
exactly who i am either that's that's
just an aspect of who i am right i don't
think it would take it away from the 12
steps to recognize those things i'm not
wrangled okay good i can hear that i
didn't i'm interested in how that would
be like if you were gonna if you were
gonna up update the big book or rewrite
the steps like how
how that could be practiced
oh um
summer
i understand
that
this
addiction that i have is not a disease
that i inherited
but it's my attempt to escape from pain
that i endured when i was too small to
do anything about it
and the more i learned about that pain
the less i'll inflict those imprints on
myself and on the people around me
how about that
that's actually beautiful i like that
yeah i i i have um
you know i'm of of two minds on on one
aspect of it which is i think it's
really important and beautiful and
powerful
for people to get up and and vulnerably
and honestly to the best of their
ability share their story right and i
get a lot of nourishment out of hearing
that and i get a lot of nourishment out
of sharing it
um but i can't help but also think
by
continuing to do that year after year
after year after year
[Music]
is that not
cementing
something that
that need not be cemented in the sense
that like i'm over identifying with this
thing that happened and saying this is
the most important thing and i can't
forget this and i need to understand
that this is who i am like crafting an
identity around that that perhaps is at
odds with
the transcendent state that i seek well
um first of all
i didn't say you had to keep doing it
for a year after year after year i just
have to incorporate it somewhere in the
process yeah number one number two let
me ask you a question if i may turn it
around
i've been waiting for you to turn it
around okay
you said in the very beginning
been a 12 stepper for 20 years now is
that the case uh yeah over over 20 years
since 98. okay great 24 years
i had a relapse yeah okay well
okay that's good so all those years
you've been pursuing the path that's
good right
salute you for it
and you said that my work made a huge
difference to you mm-hmm in the
beginning
i heard you say that
what difference did my work make to you
uh the difference that it it it it
allowed me to think about and confront
and begin to
uh deconstruct
the childhood trauma piece and how did
that help in a compassionate way
that has allowed well how how it's
helped me is it's given me peace and
solace like i've been able to make peace
okay with my upbringing and that in turn
has dramatically impacted my
relationship with my parents in a very
healing way and how about children
and yes and then i wanted to ask you
about parenting because that in turn
has been very informative in thinking
about how i how i parent my children
from a perspective of nurturing and
trying not to make the mistakes that
could unduly or unnecessarily okay so go
ahead
here's my question to you then
then what's the problem
what do you mean well did it make you
stuck in some victim role dealing with
that trauma no so it doesn't need to
that's the whole point yeah
it actually what i hear you saying is
that you did the 12 steps they were
wonderful for you they continue to be
wonderful for you but this trauma
awareness add another dimension yeah and
i'm not i'm not resisting that i told
you i think that that would you know
what i know you're not resisting but
you're asking me the question if i
understand you was asking me will it
make people stuck in the victim role i'm
saying no
right i think i was asking more about
the self-identification piece like in
the construct of 12 step where you know
the meetings have a very particular kind
of uh structure to them right
and it it's it's that one thing that you
do
and doing that year after year after
year does that unduly create uh a craft
kind of a a
a solidified identity around an aspect
of your life that remains kind of
untouched you know what i mean so it was
less about pushing back on you and
trying to better understand the
therapeutic dynamic of uh okay
okay yeah yeah and i understand
look
i think that's for people in the tour
steps to answer it but it's a good
question to raise
is is how are we doing things helping to
at the same time is it helping us
gain agency over our addictive patterns
is it also entrenching us in that kind
of self-identity
yeah that's not
it's not for me to tell you that because
i've not been in the movement and i'm
you know but i think it's a really good
question to raise within so that's
another question to raise within the
trust of movement in other words
um
it's a movement like any other it can be
dynamic it can both honor its founding
principles and at the same time uh
evolve you know and i think trauma
awareness and this question of
self-identification would be good
questions to raise within the torso
movement yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's i think it's tricky i mean
when i mentioned a few moments ago that
i'd relapsed that
at
over 10 years in i had a very brief
relapse and i was
back in the meetings right away yeah but
it was quite the wake-up call and i can
tell you that when i picked up it's you
know that adage of like your your
addiction is doing push-ups in the dark
just waiting for that moment it was very
much the case and it was frightening
because all the work that i'd done and
the thousands of meetings and treatment
and the like
[Music]
it was shocking
how
how
i could just forget that in a moment
and be immediately back
right where i was when i stopped
thinking so in that sense of like like
in recovery versus recovery clearly not
recovered i had come a long way but it
was also a kind of an ego check and a
dose of humility to remind me that
although i had
i've i i had i have grown in many ways
that there was still so much growth
there that i was in denial over you know
confronting and dealing with look so
yeah i get it and uh
it's like people say to me
you know thank you for writing your
books
they saved my life
and some years ago my answer would have
been gee that's good maybe i should read
them myself you know so that yeah we
stumble and we fall and we don't live up
to our own best
intuitions and understandings
but i would dispute with you you said
you were back where you started no you
weren't
you were not back where you started you
stumbled
but back when you started the world
taking you much longer to stand up again
fair enough and this time it didn't so
it's not like all that work you did all
of a sudden just disappeared and you had
to start from the beginning you did not
have to start from the beginning
you just had to stand up again
so
even that relapse and how you dealt with
it
showed how much transformation is
possible
and it did not in any way invalidate the
fact that you're still on the path to
recovery yeah
yeah
it was definitely uh
upsetting when it happened well of
course it was upsetting yeah
yeah of course believe me i've been
there yeah
um
[Music]
i think it would be helpful to share a
little bit you know back to the
parenting thing for you know people who
have young children who are trying to
consciously you know guide their kids
and sidestep some of these pitfalls that
are unduly causing kids problems that
you know so i think
parents are well intentioned when the
when everybody says oh you should let
that kid cry it's because that's what
doctors and professionals and experts
are telling us i used to myself right so
yeah so what are some you know
touchdowns that you could
share with people about that well
so
there's a parenting instinct
that we share with other mammals even
birds
it's distinctive
but instincts have to be evoked by the
environment
so the first thing to realize is that
our environment doesn't evoke our
perennial instincts in fact they put
them to sleep
like if you take for example the
case of
children not being picked up when
they're crying
what do the parents actually feel when
they're doing that
to stress their heart is breaking
but to fit in with the culture and to go
along with the so-called experts
and maybe for their own convenience they
actually ignore their parenting
instincts
now the more we ignore our parenting
instincts
the more they shut down
so the first point is
for god's sakes listen to your parenting
instincts don't listen to the experts
they don't know what the heck they're
talking about
[Music]
uh
listen to your important instincts first
number one number two
uh
human beings
and mammals actually
are
evolved in a way
that the most important dynamic in our
lives is actually love and connection
and love and connection is the
the
very ocean
in which human life human life evolves
that's much more important than which
parent technically use or
or
or what
now this society breaks that connection
very early
because in in the united states 25 of
women
go back to work within two weeks of
giving birth
that is traumatic to the child
if you look at how
human beings evolved
children were with their parents all the
time they were held all the time
physically held all the time
they were not hit
and the average age of weaning was
between three and five years
so that now
i'm not saying we can go back to being
hunter-gatherers
but i am saying that
recognize that
our basic needs have been in this
society really denied so
some people can't help going back to
work that's their economic situation
that's part of the toxicity of our
culture
but
as much as possible
at least let's see what those children
are losing and give them as much
loving and connection as possible
don't make it even worse by parenting
practices that undermine the
relationship
in this society children get far too
hooked on their peers far too early
i don't know if you read my book hold on
to your kids no i didn't read that one
well yeah if you know
your youngest one who's 14 so it might
be too late maybe maybe i don't know you
know but
but our children
by default
end up de developing important
relationship with one another at the
expensive relationship with the parents
that's why they spend all their time on
facebook trying to connect with each
other because they're looking for
contact and connection that they should
have got from the adults
but they're not
and so now they turn to each other
and each other is a very inadequate
replacement for wise nurturing adult
contact
so be aware of we just need to be aware
of all that's lost in this culture and
do as much as we can to restore it
within the limitations of our existence
yeah
beautifully put and furthermore
so much of the parenting advice
to kids is about how do we get this
behavior or that behavior
so um
in the book i give the example of a
this is
a true story of a
mother yelling at a five-year-old who
doesn't want to do his homework
five-year-old imagine if harvey will not
want to do his homework he wants to play
yeah which is he shouldn't have hallmark
in the first notes
by the way play is an essential
developmental need of human beings
as it is of all mammals we have a system
in our brain
organized around play
and that has to be honored that's why
little cats and little dogs they play a
lot
it's not just fun and games it's how
their brain develops okay so this
five-year-old
is not doing as long as mother yells
you're not thinking of your academic
future
and
our line in the book is where if the kid
could yell back
he would yell but you're not thinking of
my developmental needs
we have to honor children's
developmental needs
and we have to put the developmental
needs ahead of our agenda
for their behaviors
if the developmental needs are met
they're going to learn beautifully
you don't have to push them they'll be
curious they'll be spontaneously
interested
they'll want to find out about things
they'll want to gain mastery
and learning will be a joy for them
that's not what we do
we demotivate them with all the pressure
that we put on them yeah so there's so
many ways in this culture where we could
do things better if we only understood
what the actual needs of children were
so what i'm saying the parent is don't
no so there's this book called [ __ ]
sheet
by emily ulster
who's a
econo economist i think
so with an economic economist brain she
looks at all these studies and figures
out what's best for kids for god's sakes
it's all backwards
you know it's
much of the advice she gives is terrible
advice on parenting it's all designed
for the parents convenience right
and she's not asking
she's asking what do the parents need
but what the parents need in an abnormal
culture or what the parents think they
need in abnormal culture is it
self-abnormal and she's not asking what
are the developmental needs of the child
and how do we meet them that's a very
different question it's about how to
leverage the kids to make the parents
feel better about themselves exactly and
parents should not be looking to their
children
to you know fill that hole or mend that
wound within themselves that's right and
i think it's you know that's one thing
i've been
trying to you know maintain astute
awareness of
because of my historical patterning and
trying to resist like you know that
coming up in the way that i parent my
kids trying to love them unconditionally
and and to remain
neutral to not project my [ __ ] onto
them yeah any of those expectations or
neuroses or anxieties which is very
difficult i'm not very good at that
um
and then also like trying to figure out
the balance or the the
the line between
you know
the unconditional love
but not trying to get love from them to
meet my own needs just to love them and
you know it's like it's not the kids job
to love us it's our job to love them
but also knowing when to you know have
the healthy boundaries and erect the
guideposts and the you know
the you know when to say no and all of
that kind of stuff and i feel my like i
want my kid to like me so i want to and
it's like all this baggage comes up that
makes it really
murky and and
um
challenging for me well if i'm gonna
give you a suggestion there's two people
i would highly recommend for you to
check out um
one of those doctor gore neufeld and
eufeld and he's a psychologist in
vancouver he's the greatest
developmental psychologist in the world
and i'm saying that not because he's my
friend but because that's what i
truly found
and he's the one who's the main author
of this book we wrote called hold on to
your kids where parents need to matter
more than their peers that book will
blow your mind
number one number two dr dan siegel here
in los angeles who's written a book
called uh parenting from the inside out
and it's all about how not to project
all your stuff on your kids yeah and how
to recognize when you're doing it right
so i think that gordon would be an
amazing guest for you and i think dance
eagle would be an amazing guest i just
wrote both of their names down sorry i
just wrote both of their names oh yeah
yeah check out those books and i think
if you want to talk to parents and if
you want to enhance your own parenting
you could really learn from those people
right
uh final thing just because i have you
here and i have to ask because this is
just going on right now so i have two
teenagers and part of that phase of life
is disconnecting a little bit from the
parents and developing their own agency
and there's a little bit of
um emotional withdrawal going on right
now which is natural at some level yeah
but
as a parent
there's
it's sort of like suddenly this person
who you thought you knew becomes a
complete mystery and is less
demonstrative about their interior life
and
i'm always like how do i find a way in
how can i maintain
that open communication and that level
of connection when there is a natural
pulling back that
should be you know sort of appreciated
at the same time
well
that's a very delicate question you just
asked
because
that withdrawal on your
child's part can mean one of two things
it could mean a healthy individuation
which is what nature intends for them
they need to individuate they need to
become separate autonomous
people with self-agency
[Music]
so it could reflect that but it could
also reflect an alienation from you and
then moving deeper into the peer group
which is not a sign of individuation but
a sign of conformity
so it's hard to know
if you look at
i think reading hold on to your kids
would really help you with that one
but
at the same time if you look at
traditional societies
young people did not withdraw from their
parents
they became individuals in connection
with their parents
in fact they were initiated into adult
society
by the elder generation right
so
individuation and mature maturation
become your own person doesn't
necessarily
involve in fact does not involve
alienation from the parental generation
i think that's very much an artifact of
our culture so
i don't know what's going on with your
particular kid but it could be
sign or
somewhat
of a
[Music]
not so healthy withdrawal
and
i'd have to know more about it to tell
you which it is but it's important to
consider which it is yeah i'm gonna
think about that that's actually really
helpful yeah yeah
um i think we have to let you go
uh which is a shame because i could talk
to you for hours and hours and hours but
i really appreciate your time today i do
i say this in all honesty and
earnestness the the myth of normal i
really think is a groundbreaking book
um perhaps your most impactful book to
date and that's saying a lot because in
the realm of hungry ghosts
i know has been so instrumental in my
life and in the lives of millions of
people so
you're a gift my friend and i wish you
well and i'm at your service if there's
anything i can do to help you in the
meantime everybody who's watching or
listening please pick up the myth of
normal it comes out september 13th
uh and if you haven't read in the realm
of hungry ghosts it's it's it's
mandatory reading for anybody who wants
to better understand not just addiction
but
humanity really
and i think just to close this out
uh what we do need above all in this
kind of conversation about moving back
to a holistic relationship with
ourselves others in the planet is a
return to empathy and deeper
understanding which is at the core of of
all of your work right it's like to
understand these things
uh you can't help but develop a greater
capacity for for empathy for
the
painful human condition that on some
level we we all experience and i find
you to be a deeply empathetic person and
it's no mystery that
this work has become uh that you know
that is a passion for you is is so
impactful for so many other people well
thank you and um let me then
end with a quote from one of my mentors
h almost is a psychologist spiritual
leader and
he says that
only when compassion is present well
people allow themselves to see the truth
and so
my commitment is just to speak the truth
as i see it
and to see it as clearly as i can and
for that
you
both need compassion and the more you
see the truth the more compassion
actually becomes a natural attribute of
of how you move in the world
beautiful
thank you
well thank you come back again sometime
thank you all right peace
[Music]
you